I had amnesia I
had no memory of anything until I was 8 years old
But during today's match that last shot
brought back my memory That alone makes coming to Japan worth it I
didn't know that Eve had no memory  I did
n't say it, so I'm
glad I got my memory back. Aoi: I came to Japan because I met you.
What
did you say during the game that your father's name is Kazuhiko
Hodaka
?  It's true, my father's maiden name is
Kazuhiko Hodaka 16 years ago, he was adopted by his son-in-law in the rain and
changed his name to Kazuhiko Amashi.
That's strange No, that's right, what my
dad said in my memory I'm my only daughter in the world
That's a
lie, I'm your father's daughter  I
deny my father's words
[music]
You're really my daddy's daughter It's
not a hit You've
been by my side since I was born You taught me how to play golf
Eve is a lie  Don't tell me I'm not lying
Then someone is lying